when it comes to construction drawings
they are the riskiest element of an
architect's practice
at the same time they're also the most
expensive part of your entire contract
so that's why i always recommend a good
checklist to make sure you're always on
track
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk about architecture
and technology today i wanted to share
my insights as a registered architect in
the state of western australia
on the construction process i wanted to
provide you with my checklist that i use
to make sure that i haven't left
anything off a construction set of
documentation so what i've done is
created a digital checklist with 10
pages and over 200
notes to go through that means there's
all sorts of different information that
we're going to go through step by step
to make sure that we don't miss anything
of our drawings the first plan we have a
tendency to show is the site plan
the site plan depicts as much as you can
possibly see
so the purpose of the site plan is to
actually annotate and outline
the boundaries so where is our working
space where can we actually do the job
when we start to break down the site
plan it's a very
simple plan at the essence it generally
shows the position of the building
in relation to the site boundaries so
all we're really looking for on the site
plan is
details about the actual building the
size the building the driveways the
landscaping we're also talking about
things like
downpipes storm water hydraulic systems
civil engineering and everything that
has to do with the site
so if you're demolishing a bunch of
trees it needs to be noted if you're
adding
60 giant trees it needs to be noted
wherever your letter boxes go wherever
your clothes lines go
everything that's outside and needs to
be depicted is usually just shown
generically on the site plan now after
the site plan we move on to our next
page of the checklist
if you're interested this checklist is
available in full to download in the
link down below
the next page in the checklist is the
floor plan the floor plan
is genuinely about showing details of
the actual house itself
now this checklist can be used
generically for a house or a commercial
project the elements are very similar we
will use a house in this example
just for the convenience factor the
floor plan indicates all your internal
walls or your external walls
and everything that you need to know
about the inside so wherever your
kitchen cabinetry goes
wherever your sinks are wherever your
showers are your toilets and
all your plumbing fixtures and it isn't
just physical locations we want to be
able to detail as much as possible
so every door and window that you see
has to be annotated
we want to start using door and window
tags we also want to annotate and use
wall
tags for every single different wall
type there is in the construction
process
this can be exported out into a
completely different plan if you want
but most of the time on simple smaller
jobs
it is shown on the actual floor plan the
floor plan needs to be dimensioned
as thoroughly as possible if somebody's
to go build that house
you want them to be able to know exactly
where a wall is going
or exactly where a unique item in that
design has to go
floor plan has a tendency to be
scattered and littered with notes
you want to be showing things like the
room names the ceiling heights
if there's a raking ceiling or a
coffered ceiling or
any sort of bulkhead whatsoever you want
to be able to annotate
anything on that floor plan that isn't
obviously visible and speaking of not
visible you want to make sure that you
can see
all the beams and trusses above as well
so usually it's annotated with a very
simple dashed line
that indicates there is a beam above and
it's noted as well what beam that is
so when somebody begins constructing it
they don't miss a critical element of
the process
if it's a much larger building you might
also be using construction grid lines
they usually run one through to nine
across the top and
abc down the side depending on how you
actually draw this might be inverted
completely
it doesn't really matter how you do it
as long as there is some sort of
reference
you can do one through to 100 and one
through 100 on the side and then you
just go
one and one it's just an annotative grid
to be able to position and locate things
most of the time this is spread along
column lines so that you know where your
column spacing is perfectly from the
get-go along with everything else that
goes on the floor plan you don't want to
miss
any of your elevation or section markers
and you especially don't want to miss
any of the detail markers that come a
little bit later on
now this is definitely not the time to
get lazy and comfortable
your elevations come next in your
working drawing package your elevations
might seem simple and generic you're
just showing the outside of the building
however it is very critical that some
key elements are shown on the elevation
the elevations depict the architectural
expression of that building so if you
have a particular type of cladding that
you want on there
you make sure you specify it you make
sure you show every downpipe and where
it runs
because the last thing you want to be
doing is telling a client that
unfortunately we have to shift a window
across or move an element in that design
because the down pipe has absolutely
nowhere to go
so things like this are critical on the
elevations there's something that you
don't want to be missing and making
mistakes on
later down the track it also gives the
builder some key height references
they know exactly where a window needs
to go they know exactly where the doors
are how high they are how wide they are
it's simple information that is shown on
every single elevation
but it is critical to the construction
process now most times than not you can
also see
the roof structure on an elevation
sometimes it's a hidden roof and that's
okay you don't have to show it on this
but if it's a generic roof a hip and
valley or a raking roof
then unfortunately you're gonna have to
show the pitch on that elevation as well
because if you go ahead and just draw a
single pitch roof with a 5 degree slope
and don't tell the builder that
information how they're going to build
it
they need to know exactly what pitch
that roof needs to go
to be able to build it exactly how you
envisioned and you remember those grid
lines we're talking about a second ago
those grid lines need to be shown on the
elevation as well so don't forget that
your grid lines
have to be seen on elevation floor plan
and also section sections are where this
project gets really critical
this checklist here in my hand is
designed to help you get through these
sections and not forget little details
sections at work in drawing stage or the
construction stage are all about
details it's all about the construction
and build-ability
of that section you're drawing you want
to pick section lines that are important
to the project you don't want to be
cutting through
one robe and leaving it at that you want
to be cutting things
like stairs bathrooms where there's set
downs
where there's a raking ceiling or a
feature ceiling you want to be showing
as much detail in one single section as
you possibly can so in section we show
that at about a one to fifty scale
which gives us enough detail to show
most of the generics of that building
we go further into sectional details a
little bit later on where they're 1 to
10 or 1 to 20
but for the most part sections show all
the information we need
in a section you have to outline how the
floor connects to the ground
how that ground connection then connects
to the wall and how that wall connects
the roof
you want to show how all those internal
walls connect to the slab as well
is there a second floor above you how's
that held up
what's that second floor made of the
sections that need to be annotated in
great detail
you want to be pointing to everything
structural
so for example if you have structural
beams running across the ceiling you
want to annotate and note them
you want to point out what roof cladding
you're using what purlins you're using
any single structural element needs to
be shown here you also want to annotate
things like set downs in the slab for
wet areas
so if you need to set down that slab 40
mil to be able to allow for your tile
fall
in the wet areas you need to annotate it
otherwise it won't get built
it's important that we show every single
height here as well height markers are
critical in every single view
we want to know where the ground floor
starts what reference level that is
where the ceiling starts where it stops
where the next floor starts
how high each individual stair is if
you're cutting through a set of stairs
you really want to show as much possible
detail in this section
about the construction process from an
administrative side of things
you don't want to be forgetting about
all your room names
so it's important that when somebody
picks up that section and goes
oh yeah i know exactly where this is it
isn't taking them
20 minutes to figure out where that
section cuts through you also want to be
showing those
special grid lines we talked about
before if they are depicted on your
project
you need to make sure that all your
detail markers are shown for every
single detail that you want to
actually provide architectural influence
on otherwise the builder's just going to
build it however they say fit now one of
the last things on this very long
section list
is control joints i'm mentioning this
one specifically
because if you do have two materials
joining that need some sort of control
joint
well then it's something that's going to
have to be shown in section
the next page is the roof plan if it
wasn't gailing winds
and rain outside right now i'd go sit on
my roof to actually articulate this
point a little bit better
but unfortunately it's pretty miserable
so we're going to try to use a high up
angle
to reflect what we could usually see
from up top
the roof plan is all about the actual
roof structure and what's going on
so we need to annotate our roof covering
we need to show our purlins which
direction they're going
we need to showcase all our flashings
and our gutters our
downpipes how big are the downpipes how
wide are they what color are they
where do they actually go we need to
showcase the gutters in great detail is
it a box cutter
does it need to be 300 600 wide this is
some information that's
always shown in the roof plan and
something that shouldn't be forgotten
similar to how we had to show the pitch
on the elevation we also have to show
the pitch on the roof plan we also want
to show
elements like the ridge any valleys any
hips
if it's a hip and valley roof or what
direction it's actually raking in
so just some generic annotations for the
roof
that needs to be shown on this plan if
it's a much larger job and you're using
a mechanical engineer for example
you also need to depict where their
elements need to go where's the air
conditioning system going where's the
condensers going are you screening that
where's the platform and how do you get
up to that platform to maintain those
systems
these are all the details that you have
to think of or at least be provided with
by the mechanical engineer to showcase
on your drawings usually if a mechanical
engineer is involved you run out of roof
space pretty quickly on a small roof
so what happens if the client wants some
solar panels on there
well you're going to have to make room
for those solar panels in the most ideal
location
depending on where you are living around
the world solar panels take up a decent
amount of space and can take up the
whole roof if they want to
they can actually form part of the roof
so if they do form part of the roof like
for example a tesla solar roof
then that's something you want to
annotate and outline straight away on
this plan
because it's a critical element to the
design if your structural engineer for
example
doesn't know there needs to be solar
panels on the roof well they can go
ahead and design
standard purlins and standard beams that
can't support the weight
of those solar panels and if they can't
support the weight of the solar panels
they
definitely can't support the weight of
any mechanical systems
so these two elements need to inform the
structural engineers decision
on what purlin sizes what beam sizes or
what trust sizes they use to be able
to support the weight it's not as simple
as just chucking some solar panels on
the roof and hoping for the best
housekeeping like always you need to
show those grid lines you need to show
those section markers you need to show
those elevation markers
you want to showcase everything that
you've shown on all the other floor
plans
your electrical plan comes next the last
thing you want to be doing
is moving in and having no electrical in
that house
so if your client comes in and can't
plug in their fridge they're going to be
pretty upset
what we show on the electrical plan
comes down to what the client actually
wants
the basics are obvious we have all of
our lighting be it
pendants hanging lights down lights
recessed lights whatever
we have to show where those light
switches go are they dimmable are they
two-way switches what kind of
lights are they actually then we want to
go into details such as powerpoints how
high up are they where are they located
how many of them are usually with
powerpoints in studies especially
there's also data and phone lines
and things like that to consider if it's
an old school place or even potential
business
fax lines are important as well it's not
that simple we also have to show
all of our mechanical services all of
our power points for those mechanical
services
all the vents all the manholes all the
hot water units outside
do we have a pool outside do we have a
pump that needs to be required
do we have a spa outside anything that
requires some sort of electrical service
needs to be detailed and showcased as
much as possible
on the electrical plan the electrical
plan is a very clean
simple minimalistic version of the floor
plan
that has all the same annotations the
same markers
elevation markers section markers
gridlines etc
but it's just showcasing our electrical
items and now because you have 101
electrical items on that floor plan
don't forget the legend as well
now it's time to showcase a little bit
more detail in the actual rooms that
require knowledge
your room layouts become critical to
understand where elements in your
kitchen and your bathroom need to go
sometimes you do need to show internal
room layouts for specific items like
some cabinetry
or a shelf or anything of those sorts of
works that requires attention to detail
some people do them in robes as well if
it is a detailed robe
however if it's just shelves evenly
spaced you don't need to do them
with an internal room layout it's all
about details so for example you want to
make sure you know exactly where your
dishwasher is going in a kitchen you
want to know how high
that little kickboard is you want to
know how high the benchtop is
you want to know how thick the benchtop
is is there some overhead cupboards
how high up are those overhead cupboards
is there a bulkhead as well
these are all the details that we have
to showcase on the internal room layouts
if there's some electrical features as
well
that are simply features more so than
anything else like led strip lighting
that's something you want to consider
adding into an internal room layout so
people know
exactly where it's going you want to
showcase as much detail
on the internal room layout as possible
so if you have a sink you want to
showcase what style of sync it is
what kind of mixer it is is it a hot and
cold tap or is it a mixer tap
people are going to get confused very
quickly on site if they see a mixer tap
on the drawing they're going to be
flicking through
the actual specifications to find a
mixer tap
so i know it seems petty and i know it
seems like little details especially if
you have a 150 pages of specifications
but you need to show accurate
information on the drawings on internal
room layout if you're showing internal
room layouts of the bathroom for example
make sure you don't forget about
handrails toilet rails or anything that
has to be fixed to the wall now this
might seem like an obvious one
but you need to showcase a door and
window schedule
doors and windows are often forgotten
about or they're completely done
incorrectly the door and window schedule
needs to accurately reflect
every detail that you've put on every
other page so if you've dimensioned the
windows and the doors on your floor plan
the overall size needs to be exactly the
same if you put height markers on your
elevation
the overall height needs to be exactly
the same the seal height needs to be
exactly the same
if it's inconsistent in any way shape or
form somebody's going to be giving you a
call and asking
what is going on where does it actually
go now i know there's a lot of
information in this video especially for
somebody to remember and write down
so if you do want to download this
checklist it's just in the link below
i'll make sure it's the first one to
make it easy for you guys with the door
and windows schedule it's a visual
representation of every single door and
window
you want to show a picture of that door
and window at the top and then you will
start listing some items below
you want to have those window tags so
you know exactly what window you're
looking at
you want to know how many of those
windows or doors you need
you want to know which way they swing or
which way they're open you want to know
what type of frame material they are
what kind of
color they are do they need a fly screen
do they not what kind of hardware is on
there
do you have a simple lock and key what
kind of key is it are they all key to
like
it's very simple details that can be
obviously discussed
during the project but it's something
that you want to take control of at the
start
especially if you're dealing with energy
efficiency homes so for example in
australia
we only use single glazing that's going
to rapidly change in the next couple of
months where we're going to go to double
glazing as a standard
so you're going to have to start noting
double glazing
as a standard in all drawings to make
sure that nobody stuffs up
and cheaps out and goes put some single
glazing in completely ruining the energy
efficiency rating of that house
okay so we're on the second last page of
this checklist now
and this is one of the most critical
elements of the construction process
we're talking about construction details
here the construction details are
usually used
to depict architectural details as well
as structural details themselves
so for example if we're having a
connection detail where a window seal
meets a wall frame and you want to
annotate
exactly how that window still needs to
be finished then you have to annotate it
and depict it in exactly the manner you
want it to be built
so if it's just a simple recessed seal
it might be that easy
but you want to blow it up to a 1 in 20
scale maybe a 1 in 10 scale if it's
quite small
and list every single item there is
there you want to literally list
everything
so if you have what type of glazing it
is what type of frame it is
what type of cladding is on the outside
how the trim is how it's flashed how
it's sealed
is there any waterproofing there what
about silicon you also need to think
internally as well as externally
so what kind of plasterboards on the
inside what color paint is on the inside
is there a corner scene in that detail
what about skirting every single
literal detail that you would see if you
went on that house
and somehow magically just cut out that
one little section
you need to be able to annotate the same
works with the floor plan details
if there's a connection plate on the
floor plan that you need to showcase
show it in as much detail as possible
because if you don't show the detail
it's going to get built
however the builder wants and usually
it's the cheapest
nastiest method the last page on the
checklist is your consultants
so these consultants are potentially
necessary potentially not necessary
there is a number of consultants on here
for a diverse range of jobs
a total of 20 consultants is found at
the bottom of the list
i've made a video about this previously
talking about all the consultants
but i wanted to add it at the end of the
checklist just to make sure
that you know you might need some of
these consultants at the very start of a
project or at the very end
it's more so a memory trigger or a guide
for you guys to be able to just look
back at this and go oh
architect yeah i definitely have one of
those that's me oh mechanical yep i've
got him sorted
so it's more so just a reminder than
anything else anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching
i hope you enjoyed the construction
checklist and i hope you got some good
information out of it
if you did it's the first link in the
description down below if you want to
download it
if you enjoyed this type of content make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below and because this video forms
one of my 28 videos in 28 days it would
usually be i'll see you next monday but
in this case i'll see you tomorrow